hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil now I
don't know what's beyond that door but I
want to be prepared for it and I know
I've got a lot of flamer fuel I've got
tons of it but I know it's not
fundamentally effective and I would feel
like a major douche bag if I didn't at
least use this Magnum so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna put it in my inventory
I'm gonna put the six bullets that I got
and I don't even know how many bullets
this thing can hold but I'm gonna try so
I'm going to get this out I'm gonna load
it up
it holds exactly seven bullets maybe in
the entirety of the game there's only
seven bullets to this guns name but I
got them so I'm going to save that for a
rainy day and then rely on my pistol and
SMG combo for the rest of it now I don't
know if that's a good idea it's probably
a very bad idea but you know I don't
know so what's that being said I still
don't know if I'm going to need
corrosive but I just kind of want to
hold it on me because I've got three
open spots and maybe I'm gonna do this
so I've got everything I need
there's a chair which is reminiscing the
grandma which I'm pretty sure is
Evelyn's at this point so let's go huh
I'm a brave boy
Oh wrong decor oh I made to go on this
horse ah I'm a brave boy oh no wait
wrong door again sorry I'm wrong on both
accounts this brave boy is not a smart
boy I've said that many - oh I came over
the hop tee gap alright so this has been
calcified so this stuff here has already
been dead at least it's already been
killed like something going on I mean
this is all salt this is a salt mine I
don't know what that means for a whole
lot of stuff but it means maybe it's not
gonna do so good for fungal growth yeah
I mean this this salt mine is from like
way way way back when I should probably
keep I'll probably get an herb you know
I'll probably get an herb maybe I don't
know if I will but I'm gonna try
I'm afraid by
oh I'm not as brave as I once thought I
was
I hear that grandma Mamaw oh boy ah it's
one of those bad decisions I made a lot
of those in my past but I'm gonna
readily identify this one it's a very
bad decision I'll be and even worse this
hidden to go over there into the deep
water yeah I think I'm smarter than I
know that's Magnum ammo hell yeah
good thing I got the Magnum gun I don't
just want to fire spastically into the
grandma but you know I will if I feel
threatened which is at all times
okay let's go I'm just trying to look
make sure I got everything grandma
grandma is that grandma oh that doesn't
sound like grandma that sounds like
young Evelyn maybe right I don't want a
fire oh hey well I'm not gonna fire you
try to make me waste my ammo die oh oh I
got a run okay I get it
Oh any goodies any goodies [ __ ] are ya
[ __ ] on my way yeah yeah yeah yeah
herb what I wanted what about [ __ ]
whoa hey what the [ __ ] with that
what ah go Bam Bam pokey
hey now what surprisingly a pill okay
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well
that was dumb of me to do whatever the
hell I just did Oh son of a [ __ ] staff
that with your group Oh [ __ ] dude
handled yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey no
no no no no no no no no no no one stop
it's a head shot is this open I don't
have a jacket [ __ ] ow damn it god damn
where am I
[ __ ] I reload cool boy there we go got
him down the [ __ ] loop-de-loop
anything else in here that I need am i
still worried about the imminent
collapse goddamn like shoulda brought
the shotgun now that guy's crawling back
from me
okay we gotta keep moving up whoa whee
whoa holy [ __ ] Go Go Go Go
that guy still crawling hey you know
what I'm gonna put you out of your
misery poink oh whoops there we go got
you okay you're bad you don't drop items
cause extra cursor use that all right
what we got what we got huh well bring
it on uh I gotta use more Bam's oh here
we go
there's a game you never know booby
traps and all that machine gun a mother
that's good too on full up oh I can make
I can make it help dude yeah okay that's
good and I've got this burdensome
corrosive well we [ __ ] knew you don't
let us keep their gold your head you two
ah read you like a book [ __ ] whoa I'm
gonna use this uh uh home keeping that
under me for some [ __ ] reason
[ __ ] Wow okay all right I get the
picture I get the picture I get the
picture
alright you know what oh oh Strang ammo
with muscles built into the bullet and
I'm gonna dump this juice on me that
wasn't enough goop tell me but it's
enough to keep me going
maybe if I find an herb I can eat it raw
if that dank Christian mic system
somehow all right what do we got here
there was probably other items that I
left but I didn't have time cuz I was
dying I can't jump I forgot about that
I'm incapable of jumping I'm capable of
getting stabbed in my limbs cut off but
jumping out of the [ __ ] question what
do we got here
alrighty then just gonna test that one
okay that's clean
you you're clean okay hello first
statement hi whoa big guy
Oh multiple big guys okay I can deal
with this
I just gotta set up my bar
I don't see awful oh I don't want these
crawl over your bed good we're doing
your big goof another wall way [ __ ]
don't ask on yell oh oh god you're
bigger call that's not bigger
hello [ __ ] hell whoa putting down for
the hello God put it down put it up
[ __ ] bad whatever I get up I'm trying
to put a goddamn band down back and I
never give juice in the world for this
[ __ ]
put it down [ __ ] oh boy kind of famine
I got I got oh [ __ ] god damn it what the
[ __ ] was that all about the [ __ ] I
couldn't do anything he kept freaking
out about the [ __ ] acid whatever it
was all right let's try again be
intelligent about in the Sun without
their file what that their crime that
their fam they can't hurt that's the
thing it can really can hurt
bam bam whoa whoa he blew whoa [ __ ] no
no stop
I get you oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
drive in pain all you want you i yeah
alright fine then that's your last
hurrah least you're dead not alive
that's a good sign God spend all my
bands oh no if I wanted to do that but
definitely was Bama licious
okay I'm gonna use that a little oh
alright feeling a hundred percent little
good ammo left in there I've still got
my Magnum I'm saving that for Evelyn if
I have to shoot Evelyn which I imagine I
will cuz I don't think this is gonna
work perfectly but I'm officially out of
BAM so it's back to survival now I don't
see any more boxes but they may have
blown up and then the items fell on the
floor but I don't have any other
psychostimulants to be able to see it so
I'm just going to assume that I did good
and move on that's what I usually do
anyway I just find myself on the back
and get myself a good day yeah thereby
ignoring the fact I said that continuing
on are we going deeper into the mines
are we actually getting out of here
please
who put the lab down here anyway they
must have found something in the mines
like that's my guess the reason that the
mines are here maybe this is the
origination of the mold but that would
be too much of a coincidence that I
wouldn't appreciate that one wouldn't be
as fulfilling for the scary little
anybody through here okay no man I'm
surprised if they haven't pulled a fast
one on me during one of those hoop use
and I'm assuming these are not bombs
I feel good Lee alright what do we got
here mind map I think they always give
me the map after I'm done with the brick
in mine like what good does that do
anybody hmm alright anyway oops sorry
scratch down for a little bit need to
exercise my knees all right so we've got
bullets
we got Magnum running low on pistol ammo
but I'm only on the super heavy stuff so
that's going to be good for killing the
little guys I suppose so I bet use that
first and then spray the machine gun
ammo leader all right I don't see
anything else that I could pass the
bleeding
but maybe baby please hello I've known
who that is grandma's chair oh I think
I'm right about this well I think he
thought oh wait oh [ __ ] wait we're back
in the house
I'm the [ __ ] did that get there oh [ __ ]
oh that's the Evelyn dolly I guess it
looks like Evelyn anyway does that have
anything to do with like the little
bobbleheads that I've been breaking this
whole time oh I don't know I don't know
hi
[ __ ] hell man where am i I'm gone too
apparently
hello okay why'd you look at me why do
you always look at me I don't like the
way you look at me is there anything
else in here man it feels so long ago I
may not I know I've been playing this
game a lot but you know it feels so long
ago since I've been down here 0 1 e oo 1
e series oh oh one it was obvious from
the beginning it was there from the
beginning a oh oh one the e series the
only successful perfected a series it
was there since the beginning and we
just never noticed that what the [ __ ]
what were we supposed to think of random
numbers we didn't know that meant oh
that's really good in the way that it's
all [ __ ] this stairway
well this stairway is the birth of the
big brave boy yeah alright now I am the
monster now I have become Jeff anybody
wanna Bob out of me
hello phone gonna ring huh alright I'm
back in the guest house I didn't think
I'd be back here but here I is
yeah Ethan don't do it yeesh all right
then
me oh hey you want a shot to the face I
got plenty you just gonna stand there
like a goof mm-hmm hello hi you want to
talk Sibley okay you're gone then why
then my macrinus I'm becoming infected
aren't I
oh yes indeedy-do I am oh boy hello
hello hello
I don't remember there being anything
here before so I don't think there's
gonna be anything here now but yeah it's
been ages since I came here
we've been on one hell of a journey hmm
hi I'll give you in a second hello
anybody in here anybody at all well
these things do have changed Oh No they
blocked off my secret escape oh well
fine then I pick a fuse no not there
anymore
can I borrow on the piano okay not there
anymore all right I'll play your game
hello oh hi go chop off my arm again
don't stab me please oh I've done that
it's [ __ ] hard doesn't want to be my
daddy can guy I'd rather not so no not
again oh not again I have to face off
with Mia oh no what I want to do that
but oh oh no I don't want to face off
with me again this time it'd probably
kill her or me I don't know oh no oh no
oh [ __ ]
now before I go that way I'm just trying
to explore absolutely everything because
there was a drawer down here that needs
to be locked picked
that's right and the only place that you
could have gotten the lockpick oh now to
memory ah [ __ ] so there must've been a
lockpick somewhere hidden I just didn't
like hi what are you doing were you
laughing at you giggling at I don't know
that I'm not playing
whoa hi whoa whoa oh you're not real oh
whoa okay all right you're all real oh
no you're not real that didn't hurt at
all oh hi hey oh hey oh okay I see how
they fit whoo all right then a little
weird weird Evelyn doll here don't know
what that was all about but does this go
anywhere can I actually get out through
here or do I need to go upstairs I'm
willing to bet yeah I need to go
upstairs oh [ __ ] off ah the cheerful
relaxing music is juxtaposed though the
dreariness of it I mean it is weird
because I am seeing this during the day
but I haven't had a chance to do that
yet I guess the only place to go is
upstairs where I [ __ ] stop yes
Wow jeezum I know very scary so what I
was seeing there before was actually
Mia's glimpses into all of this she was
being whispered to by Evelyn the whole
time are you floating I don't like
floating I appreciate it can I go
through this store and surprise you Oh
burski oh come on now all right then
fine let's play it this way both kits
not scary but you know no I don't want
it I'd rather not
okay all right Ben if you did so I wanna
how that kind of hurts actually if you
cannot do that I'm gonna put a guard oh
I get it
all right I'm gonna get it hang on I got
a lot of goop juice for this I've been
saving up not often no no come on hey
you think I don't have an ample supply
of this stuff super days
four days in bed I'm a brave boy grandma
oh good boy I'm gonna sue you ma'am
war ma'am ma'am ma'am
oh [ __ ] get back get back grandma a few
year in your eyeball you oh god you're
weird
I'm going out to bars laughing oh boy
all right we're giving pal [ __ ] now
whoa hey come on now I got powerful gun
oh look up in there oh [ __ ] dude
then I win somehow the [ __ ] no I didn't
win I did not win - holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
wanna hug our kisses on the cheek huh
you smell like bengay Wow
well to the guard it is that I suppose
guarded against the Jack building-sized
Boucherie
oh [ __ ] out well it hurts a lot what do
i do oh boy don't I I'm trying to real
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] dude
how do you win against it I don't think
there is any way through how could you
Phaneuf Oh [ __ ] can I just put them
goop this on me
oh [ __ ] that's a little bit of [ __ ] dude
well I want my grandma on please quick
call your candies are harmless that
didn't kill me that didn't kill me Oh
lovely
I don't know if your kids got to be able
to I know
you did ooh I like a gun is it's like
the Magnum it better be all right I
won't miss the time to play times over
baby I got a [ __ ] where yes area I
see you there Oh may I see you home
laughs you poo watching Cudahy whoa
where you going I'll track you attract
you huh [ __ ] you thinking your runaway
huh oh that ain't good I'm standing in
the way of that
oh okay bye grandma death so dramatic
she died in slow motion honey then sit
here bleeding and dying from my multiple
contusions I'll just fill my whole body
with goop juice I'll become the
antithesis of the fungus with just goop
you're on adulterated goop ha Oh friends
yay it's the birthday party way better
than grandma's birthday party that party
sucked hello
Hidy Hidy Hidy ho how they on their
friend good thing you're not shooting me
right away
so you're gonna kill me someday do you
happen to work for a company that's
related to rain paraphernalia
oh my god so Hanford view oh let me
found you the [ __ ] took you guys talk
Chris that Chris before the steroids oh
my gosh it's so funky
that's so weird super oh hi Oh Mia
you're not dead
Oh
I am glad yeah you did
oh this is so happy how does it go wrong
all right ear and in one door closes
another opens
well a door closed tonight and what a
long night it was but not just for me
me and I weren't the only victims here
so were the Baker's it was that thing
everyone who made them that way
aah aah
and you guys are here to clean up in
that yeah what a bunch of noble dudes ah
now she's back and once I start over for
all this behind it
oh boy maybe this is where the next door
open oh yeah I bet that's a fun door
that opens there oh that's going to be a
good one so that is very important to
realize there and I think I think I'm on
the right track here it's very important
because this is now officially before
the zombie apocalypse and what is this
oh it's the music but I don't know what
this is we'll be looking at here oh it's
a really creative credit sequence oh
that's awesome this game was fantastic
but I've got a lot to talk about before
I finish this basically this happens
before I'm pretty sure this happens
before the zombie apocalypse and I'm
pretty sure that that's Chris Redfield
before everything went to [ __ ] because
that's what umbrella corporation was he
was part of a team when in Resident Evil
1 and I haven't played the remake of it
yet but I want to play it but what this
is and why this is important to realize
now is now this game is a launching
point for the rest of the timeline when
they made Resident Evil 6 they kind of
knew they [ __ ] it a little bit they
they knew they convoluted the story just
a little bit too much but now that
they've got a new launching point with
Resident Evil 7 in a new way with
first-person shooter and just pure
terror
it gives it a great platform to be able
to move forward and expand the Resident
Evil story in a greatly different way
than we've ever seen before because it
was always third-person and there's
something to that I'm not trying to
discredit that the evil within was in
third person and it was really cool to
play that game it got really [ __ ]
weird but this one was weird but also
grounded and it was really like
interesting to see this because I can
see now how if umbrella corporation was
using this as a test project
and like then they would realize that
the fungus was too unpredictable and
couldn't be controlled and like
depending on that without having three
program things would leave them to go to
different alternatives or maybe they're
just trying to hold give bunch of
different things either way it was so
[ __ ] cool I love it I love that every
bit of that was so cool so also that
meant the other little bound up bodies
those were letters A through D of the
experimentation on this project that did
not succeed they were the ones that died
before they were able to develop and
then Evelyn the e-series is the one that
succeeded but she grew old very rapidly
so her true body was the old lady
everybody is dead baby everybody's dead
so she was aging rapidly so who knew how
long she would last anyway so for all
that regenerative ability it didn't do
her very much good if she was just
spending her entire body thin on
spreading this fungus around but who
knows if you would have died of old age
anyway this it's just so fascinating to
see all right it looks like there's an
unskipable so I'm going to do what I
usually do on to let this run and then
I've got even more two more to cover
very soon if the injections are skipped
product will age rapidly 25 times faster
than normal
ah that explains it hello hi hello it's
oh okay
like I almost got all the coins holy
[ __ ] I got all the files oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where the files
I almost got all the mr. Everywhere's
whoa I did a lot of good holy [ __ ]
weapon Albert oh one R oh nice okay the
secrets of defense oh great okay can I
get the C whoo
[Music]
Wow I don't know what that means that
Chris doesn't look this you know baby is
Chris used to maybe this is younger less
able brother Derek Derek Redfield
but anyway so that is the end of the
game but I have to check I have to check
to see what happens if you pick Zoe I
literally cannot not check that I need
to check that I have to so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna load up a game and
hopefully I've got the old one special
decree Kashiram create the serum create
the serum creates a serum create the
serum and blah blah blah blah where am i
oh I'm right here oh okay
one of that guns in there woo yay I've
got goodies ooh was that reduces damage
when guarding effects and maximized when
pairs with the essence of defense okay
cool I guess Albert woo well what kind
of bullets does the Albert take stop
that no no no no no no no oh it does
take the normal pistol ammo oh good I've
got better gun now well that's handy
that's handy-dandy alright so I'm gonna
need to explore of it there's one other
thing that I wanted to get before I
continue on uh something that I missed a
while back and I totally forgot about
but I'm gonna go back and get a nice ass
blast this I forgot about this I said I
was going to come and get that and I
totally forgot about it because I'm a
big dumb goofy goober and I got this I
guess which is good I suppose
hi what are you you come from hello
oh okay alright so someone told me that
there was something underneath the porch
ah a gun repair kit so I can use that
either on the handgun or this broken
shotgun that's what it was oh it all
makes sense I was running down a
checklist of things that I've forgotten
and things that you guys have told me oh
that makes so much sense oh how about
try that well holy [ __ ] old-fashioned
shotgun doesn't hold much ammo but packs
quite a punch we're good well hot damn
hot damn I've got a more efficient
shotgun uh whatever fun that doesn't
matter what matters is I've got this
tape and I have not looked at this I
don't know if this contains like another
gameplay sequence because ever oh my god
it would why wouldn't it happy birthday
experiment can trespassing idiots solve
puzzles Clancy javis testing area friend
thank you I want sake some a [ __ ]
no I axes you what you don't believe me
this joy well you can't fake this and
it's all for you oh come now don't be
like that just go much fun just you wait
I get it
oh these videos have always been a
teaching tool oh my god that's so cool
I mean unnecessary I went into the same
way because I just died and then
relearned everything but there's gonna
be Oh
[Music]
yes that's awful but I've already gone
through that yeah suck it up so ah oh hi
that's a sturdy camera
happy birthday huh how that camera
survived how's he holding that camera
was it a head camera the GoPro on your
forehead okay so I didn't miss much by
missing that right so those are just the
accessory things that I was going to do
now comes the main business here which
is a matter of going and fighting paw
paw seeing what happens if you don't use
the serum on them and then using the
serum on Zoey I don't imagine I'm gonna
be able to get out of using it on the
dad but maybe I can get away I don't
know who knows well geez here come the
arms here come the zoms whoa
holy [ __ ] well [ __ ] you then
my life is good Oh baby oh baby oh baby
real Oh be found popovich be really
really Whomper oh hey fantastic
oh boy I like of this gun I like it a
lot I'm in the warning shot
be mad at me ah [ __ ] it
okay that's interesting I sure wish I
had more reload speed
what are those man you got it I know how
this works oh hi
I gotta kick your ass again and I'll go
down there come on now be a friendly
friendly own its back feet time to go
back to Old Faithful old shiny bun oh
hey how's it going
Ethan I'm drumming whoa whoa no
and I'm gonna see what happens it
probably you'll just kill me buy it
again I don't know about that I'm
getting good look at him like an ugly
piece of [ __ ] maybe I don't wanna maybe
I wanna know how that's my body wait a
minute something's wrong here let me do
that from the start okay so that that
decides it well you are you can't not
indict them that's a definite all [ __ ]
here we go hello I can this one this is
beyond okay I don't know probably I feel
bad now there's only one left
they can't just be one left the hell are
we gonna do now I don't know you do you
tell me I don't know what I'm even doing
here oh okay all right sorry Mia I'm
sorry I really am but Zoey will be able
to guide the choice to safety and then I
can come back for you go I don't want to
hear it both of you just call okay all
right I've been oh I'm going going my
face is here it's hard okay cool
ridiculous don't be ridiculous
I saw the job to do I don't know what
that job is and I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know anything
about what's going on and no tanker that
exploded that you worked on for the
Umbrella Corporation I don't know
nothing about that
bye-bye my smooches love you bye i doing
not nice lovely night for a ride I guess
huh
so does it just continue that oh man it
does unless those cataclysmically ends I
don't think it would do that though oh
that's so weird like it seems so weird
to be taking Zoey like who would choose
that automatically thank you I can't
either he is no good to anyone right now
but we must make it out of here in one
piece I want to know what all this is
about starting with me me it came here
with Evelyn that's how it started oh you
mean
hmm
now it's going to be weird is that if
you go into this section there's the
boat that Mia came with everyone came
out back go take a look I'm not going
back there I got to know what Mia was up
to what the hell is this it's her
everyone doesn't want us to leave no no
Vinnie
wait Danny Joey Joey
whoa okay so the Cure didn't work what
the [ __ ] That's not me
is that me is going on here
but how did I get here
what well that doesn't make any sense
how does Mia get here oh yeah how yeah
how in the world yeah so what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's so bizarre how does
that change things how did Mia get here
I mean I understand they're just trying
to move the plot forward anyway but if
there's Ethan he's almost dead hey
[ __ ]
wake up so it's the same way so it must
just change the actual ending and not
the events leading up to it I guess Mia
wouldn't choose Ethan but holy [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh okay so I got to the first save
point after this what I'm going to do
now is the speediest of speedruns I've
ever sped run and I'm going to try my
best to get through this
eh okay but I don't know where I'm gonna
go I don't know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna try my best here to not die but
yes it's all I really know so let's get
to it so I'm gonna be right back I'm not
gonna be very completionist about this
but I'm gonna be fast all right I'm back
this is the point where you do a
cutscene with EZ and Ethan so let's see
what the difference is here what what is
it Oh kill Ethan I don't know I don't
know if I wants him Ethan
Ethan Oh Shh I know I know I know not
gonna hurt you
so that's the same that is exactly the
same word for word so that has not
changed okay hello hi sorry for
abandoning you back there hope you can
find it in your heart to forgive me oh
no oh no flashbacks
ah thought of a kids dog no oh no no no
poor person how oh come on
haha
you Elijah
oh man I'm horrible horrible good
[ __ ] that's horrible and I don't know
how Mia got pulled into this oh why does
it all have to be so connected it's all
your fault I know I know it's my fault
at least now it has some meaning to it
at least now that declaration understand
something oh Jesus now I've got left to
do is get down at the end of the game
and see how that changes it's not too
far so long as I don't get too
interested in the items but uh I mean I
know it's not the ending that I got but
still to know that that exists why would
you pick Zoe why would anyone pick Zoe I
mean I'm sure Zoe is a lovely person and
all and any Zoe's out there you're also
lovely people it's just that I don't
know it's the choice of your wife
versus someone you barely have met one
day prior oh yeah yay I'm on push button
faster all right you know goodbye oh I
forgot that hi well whatever done there
bye MA
have fun in an [ __ ] crews busy
play what's on the can yeah yeah he's
right behind me oh hey okay Retton
frenemy hurry
well sorry Mia I think your dad so that
bode well
yeah I do yeah I do sorry see I'm kind
of curious what this thing actually did
because if anything it kind of made her
much more powerful like I think it was
supposed to kill her outright but oh my
god man it
man is so dead space by the way that I'm
ever mention I don't even think I
thought it I don't think I ever said it
incredibly death back now we can I show
you please
Wow
oh gosh now we are all ow ow ouch gibble
Wow Wow let me reload there gah brother
fine yeah where's your face ah this is
where it's gonna change the boss fight
was pretty much the same it's still day
right now so I don't know if that was
actually a difference or that was it's
all in my head you shall see hello oh
what a birthday party I had a terrible
time at Grandma's mr. Redfield
show me your handsome face you gonna
shoot me just shoot me right off the bat
that's what I thought you were gonna do
last time
maybe I got [ __ ] you're gonna shoot me
Oh
slightly different no that's the same a
Redfield
I'm glad we found you oh he's not
killing me took you guys so long
[Music]
I cannot job I gotta get back to work I
love you so much I'm sending tons of
kisses hi baby
but oh it feels bad
uh but in what world would you pick Zoe
this is totally unrealistic but in what
world would you pick Zoe and stay on one
door closes oh so hopeful
all right I'd do a close tonight but I'm
feeling good right now
and what a long that it was but not just
for me huh me and I weren't the only
victims here ah me right there no we're
acres said it was that thing
Evelyn who made them that way yeah see
that logo is completely different lose
dead and these guys are here to clean up
the mess what a bunch of heroes I know I
just come to terms of losing me in the
first time but now I've lost her again
and the only other door I can see is
closed oh not quite so hopeful not quite
so hopeful
there you have it oh man if there's
another ending I don't have time to find
it because I spent a long time getting
to this one the speedrun was still slow
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
skip this I'm gonna skip this and
bada-bing bada-boom got a Bing bong Bing
bong boom oh I didn't even have to wait
through that for that okay cool well
that's cool either way that is the end
of Resident Evil 7 there's been quite a
trip I've already said everything that
was on my mind about this and there's
all sorts of theories that I could spit
out forever and ever but I'm very tired
and I've just played through the ending
twice now to get to both of them just to
see what could happen I don't know who
in the world would ever pick Zoe over
Mia just in a rational mindset your wife
is there even if like she tried to kill
you I guess you know hey go with the go
a say evil you know versus the evil you
don't know you know that kind of that
kind of choice between it but this was a
fantastic game and a welcome welcome
change to the Resident Evil series it's
super interesting how they blended
combat in it very well made combat very
strenuous reloading getting trapped it
was very very tight it was well tuned I
liked it a lot I might be playing it on
hard mode on my own just because I like
this game a lot but I can't wait to see
what they do in the future
but I do think I do think this is going
to be a slightly different universe than
the one that we've seen before so with
that being said thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
I hope you enjoyed this series I want to
do more long plays like this in the
future this was a ton of fun so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
bye-bye
[Music]